[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So here's
some food for thought.
Let's talk about
layers of truth.
shades of perspective.
Because a different
perspective is literally
a different reality.
So here's a quote by
Christopher [INAUDIBLE].
He reminds us that while
gazing up at the night sky,
one in fact hangs off a
planet, and near the edge
of a galaxy, vertiginous,
it's suspended
over the infinity of space.
At any given moment
of our lives,
as we muck about a
flutter, concerned
with the trivialities
of everyday-ness,
as we tranquilize ourselves
with trivialities,
we in fact are living in a
different truth than when
we step back, zoom out,
take the long view,
expand our minds,
and consciousnesses,
and perceptions, and realize
that we, in fact, hang
over a planet
suspended in space,
spinning around at a very fast
speed at any given moment,
10 trillion atoms self-organized
into a sentient mind that
perceives itself as living off
a planet that is hanging off
of space.
I mean, there is truth to
every single thing I've said.
Every single prospective
offers another angle,
another reflection, of
the present situation.
There are many truths.
There are many realities.
They coexist side by side.
And I think the
role of the artist
is to visit those
realities, to transcend
baseline, ordinary consciousness
to change our perspectives,
to bring back souvenirs for
the rest of us to consume.
Art gives us a
glimpse of the other.
[MUSIC PLAYING]